you want to be a speaker and you're
doing speeches then the story becomes
critical you can't have a speech without
a great story but for those of you who
are doing coaching or thought leadership
kinds of videos so before you get to
your advice before you tell me about the
eight ways that I can lose weight or
whatever then you need to tell me that
you understand me this is the biggest
mistake that people make when they're
creating these thought leadership videos
is you're giving me advice but I don't
know who you are story always wins on
this platform it's probably like five
years ago I wanted to take things to the
next level and I like linked up with
some buddies and we're like let's go to
the desert let's go to Utah high
production we had drones and trucks and
cameras and wanted to make this running
thing and so excited spent more money
than I had you know and then came back
put it all together released it the next
week I wrote a speech attached it to a
still image cost zero dollars to make
and put it up and it did like 10 times
better as a Creator I had to ask myself
how do I remain authentic and do what
feels good but also stretch that so that
I can win on YouTube and so I started
writing 10 15-minute speeches very new
to me but the channel grew like
instantly
Eddie Panero ladies and gentlemen what
do you got for us man what should people
what do people need to do yeah so first
of all I'm so excited to be hanging out
I put myself in the position of like
when I started YouTube if there were
three things I I could tell younger me
what would it be
and so balance story and audience so the
first one balance the balance between as
creators or people that have Brands and
stories to tell you know being authentic
and loving what we're doing and and
creating uh passionately while also
understanding the parameters of the
platform and how to win in a specific
Arena
um
so when I started paying attention to
how to win on YouTube my channel grew
and like not kind of grew at like 20x
and what I'm talking about is like
creating content so I on my channel I
write speeches I like tell stories about
life and epiphanies and look for
inspiration in sort of the day-to-day
things I did that I made like three and
a half minute videos like little almost
like little songs
when I started working with Evan he was
basically like look watch time wins on
YouTube the you know if you really want
to grow your channel you have to have
longer videos and uh so as a Creator I
had to ask myself how do I remain
authentic and and do what feels good but
also stretch that so that I can win on
YouTube and so I started writing 10 15
minute speeches very new to me but the
channel grew like instantly same thing
with like the titling like I loved sort
of artsy cryptic type you know how like
movie titles you don't even really know
what they mean until you watch the movie
um that's what I was doing like I could
do that I could continue but
um there's disadvantages like YouTube
doesn't know what you're talking about
it doesn't you wouldn't come up in
search it doesn't know what Niche you're
in you have to be very specific
so I started changing titles and
thumbnails and uh again saw another uh
substantial growth curve so that's the
first thing it's like understanding that
balance between as creators being
authentic and loving what we're doing
but taking the time to really learn what
wins on a platform because if you marry
the two uh you see fireworks I like that
yeah yeah well no I mean of course I
like it but it's great no it's The Head
and the Heart you know it's like my
language right it's like The Head and
the Heart where if
the head is just the strategies and like
here's what you need to do to win but if
you don't love it you're not going to
win but if you're only following your
heart and there's no strategy attached
to it too then you don't end up getting
the result and so it's like in that
combination of what you love doing with
what is actually working that you start
to get some significant results and so
this is a challenge for everybody is
that in in any of these strategies that
we give you not just today but in all of
all the movement makers it's figuring
out how do you make it your own and one
of my biggest challenges in in my
YouTube career was in working with my
agent
in the same agent as Mel Robbins and
Grant Cardone and all those guys uh
they'd give me he'd give me assignments
that never quite felt right he gave me
assignments that stretch stretch me and
asked me to tell stories that like
didn't feel quite right
uh but I still did them and in the doing
of them it's it was kind of like trying
on somebody else's hat
it didn't quite fit but it got me 80 of
the way there and it gave me a a good
perspective point that then I could take
what he gave me and I just had to add my
own little customization to it and so I
love that what did you call it balancing
like your authentic self and what works
on the platform there you go yeah yeah
okay good um and then you know I can
think of of times I've been on either a
little too like the pendulum swings and
I guess it's different seasons of your
life it's okay to be one more one way or
the other but like before we had gone
into like before I met you when we
started talking shop it was way too far
to the left completely disregarding the
YouTube you know how to win on the
platform and then there are times where
like yeah it's your point like you get
so into it that you start losing that
creative spark and you can't have that
either you gotta have fun have a little
bit of both well I really think you can
you can approach it from both ways so if
you come with a great idea or something
like you love doing right like I would
love to spend my time doing this right
that's your leading with the heart and
then you got to figure out
okay how do I make this actually work
because
if I don't figure out a way for it to
work then it's just a hobby as opposed
to something that's having a meaningful
impact at the same time though sometimes
I'll come up with things where okay this
is what's really working right now this
is what's really trending right now this
is something that you know we should be
doing but it doesn't feel right so how
do I take that thing and then attach my
heart to it so thinking you can approach
it from both perspectives
um
but yeah that matching is super super
important and another thing to pay back
because this is so real to me like this
hits home when he's talking about the
agent stretching him and doing like a
lot of the times when you do things and
you explore
like learning what doesn't work is just
as important in a lot of ways because it
like allows you to then take the little
pieces that did and build them up
um so yeah when he said that I'm like oh
man for so many times where it's like I
did things in and it wasn't quite right
but it wasn't a loss because I learned
what not to do and I also was able to
Cherry protect the things that were like
on point so that's number one balance
balance what's number two item uh story
and so uh this one is is almost so
obvious that it feels like a cliche but
like uh storytellers rule the world you
know and uh
starting out like if I would put my arm
around younger me and say the tech
doesn't matter you know the looking at
the all these things and what other
people are doing like none of it matters
if you can tell a good story
you'll win um and and I have just so
many examples of of Life handing me that
lesson like the first six months of the
channel I wrote uh some speeches told
some stories that uh audios horrendous
uh I was in iMovie at the time didn't
know how to edit it's sloppy it just
looks bad
but they did very well and when I
reshare them and point people to them
today they still do well because the
message is on brand it's on point it
connects with people uh and so yeah
that's like the the biggest thing story
always wins on this platform
um I had another example is like
it's probably like five years ago
um I wanted to take things to the next
level and I like linked up with some
buddies and we're like let's go to the
the desert let's go to Utah high
production uh we had drones and trucks
and cameras and wanted to make this
running thing and so excited spent more
money than I had you know and then came
back put it all together released it
the next week I wrote a speech attached
it to a still image cost zero dollars to
make and put it up and it did like 10
times better uh again YouTube's visual
so like I'm not advocating the still
image thing but like that sort of
emphasizes the point on the second one
the story worked and it the message
connected better and that's I was like
wow you know never put the cart before
the horse again you gotta have stories
so uh that's another one yeah I like it
and that is a great Storyteller if you
if you check out his channel your world
within everything that Eddie
posts there is his own
content is his own speeches so you've
been doing it for how many years it's
almost a decade Jesus I know I know it's
crazy you're you're you're a YouTube
veteran yeah it's amazing so everything
that he's posted is is his own original
Creations that then he will put b-roll
and music and photography and everything
else on top of it if you want to be a
speaker and you're doing speeches then
the story becomes critical to you can't
have a speech without a great story but
for those of you who are doing coaching
or thought leadership kinds of videos
we've talked about the template for a
thought leadership video where it starts
with a powerful opinion context sentence
raise the stakes and then story so
before you get to your advice before you
tell me about the eight ways that I can
lose weight or whatever then you need to
tell me that you understand me this is
the biggest mistake that people make
when they're creating these thought
leadership videos is you're giving me
advice but I don't know who you are and
it's easy for people to look at you and
say well it's easy for you like great
you you already look so skinny or you
already done XYZ right it's easy for you
you don't understand me
but you do understand them because
you've been through that but they don't
know that because it's their first time
seeing you so that's where the store
becomes really important in every kind
of video so that they know what you've
been through they know that you're like
them and whether it's your story
um something in the news cycle story uh
client story if I if I say a client
story they'll usually change the gender
or change some of the things around it
just not to personally identify somebody
but the story is what gets people in to
feel like this person gets me
and then they're willing to listen to
the advice
because without the story without the
connection they won't listen to the
advice so the story part is important
uh to every kind of video whether you're
doing you know speaking videos like
Eddie uh and your goal is to be a you
know speaker on stage or any kind of
thought leadership content as well
creating unique and consistent
platforms so thought leadership success
map this is the Holy Grail this is the
whole thing all in one Graphics if
you're ever struggling like how do I
make content and how do I dive deeper
into the content I'm making this this is
this is the Holy Grail right here so
we've talked about the Senate past but I
haven't brought it up in a while and so
this is what we want to be focused on at
the Top This is a top-down approach it's
like how do you be on every platform
back to the initial topic that we're
talking about today like how do we be on
every platform while still running our
business and still not being like a
full-time influencer in all these places
right at the top it's our 10 minute
videos
and that's YouTube and Instagram lives
it's long form content that then gets
broken down and one of the things that
I've been working with a lot on with
people whether it's movement makers on
our live sessions or some big name
people that I'm that I'm working with
and helping them grow their channels
I think we're overlooking this section
here on the left a lot
what do you want to try to get business
from so yesterday I did an IG live with
Erica Lane who's who's a Movie Maker
who's been with us for sign up for the
year
um it's like well what do you what do
you want to make money at what are you
trying to sell what are you trying to
create and for her it's leadership so
she sells leadership into corporations
but she also wants to move a little
Downstream to help leaders who are just
getting started like entrepreneurs who
are building their businesses up and now
we're leading and potentially down into
self-leadership like what does it mean
to lead yourself or to lead your family
or to lead little Community groups but
like whatever you want to try to make
money doing show me the show me the
process of you doing it this is the
fastest way to start not just making
content but also having a turn into
business for you so for Erica we're
creating her her plan yesterday
in her five videos that she was going to
make
two were going to be targeting the
corporate because that's where she makes
money that's the easiest way for her to
make money right now she has a she has a
process she can somebody comes in from
corporate she knows how to how to sell
them train them give them a lot of value
so two just towards them two towards the
the entrepreneurs that are 25 employee
plus is her kind of threshold for who
she wants to work with
cool and she can help them and then one
towards the experimental self leadership
family leadership kind of stuff because
she doesn't really know she doesn't have
a business model built out around that
yet
and so I want you guys yes making
content but the more we can turn it into
business faster the easier it is to keep
going right because now we're making
some money doing it so what do you
ultimately want to sell what's your
business model what are we trying to
create who are we trying to serve and
then making content geared specifically
towards them is the easiest type to get
started it's the most fun and it leads
to revenue which allows you to continue
to build up and grow so whether it's
thought leadership which is direct to
camera stuff
coaching your your coaching clients but
it's going to be on a video mentoring is
now that that's going to be a series
you're mentioning someone on your team
you're doing interviews with people q a
Biz Dev is is massively overlooked so if
you're looking at doing
think about who could be a partner for
you and your business in build the
survey talk about the three ways to grow
your business right does the fast
passive Freedom where you're doing the
Outreach and you're direct messaging
people and trying to connect with them
and it's it's basically sales right but
through social media second one is
Partnerships where you're thinking who
can I partner with that if they knew who
I was and they were recommending me it
would lead to tremendous business for me
and then the third is thought leadership
we're creating content on on YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock Etc but in the
Partnerships we can combine them so
who's a good potential partner for your
business
and instead of just messaging them and
say hey do you want to have a coffee or
can I introduce you to my company what
I'm doing invite them as a guest on your
show
and we don't even care about how many
views that video gets necessarily it's
more about the relationship that you're
going to build
because they may not spend the time with
you to meet over coffee or take a sales
call but they love telling their store
and they love being on shows
so you use your show Even if you have a
tiny Channel you ask them to be a guest
on your show and that builds the
relationship because you're going to
spend time with them they're gonna
they're gonna get to know you like you
trust you right they're gonna love you
and they're gonna ask what do you do
what's your what's your deal what are
you all about which thing gives you the
chance to talk about your business
and a lot of great Partnerships will end
up happening as results so people
definitely Overlook the biz Dev part and
then the document is going to be you're
showing the behind the scenes of your
life of your business that's usually the
hardest one to make takes the most
editing which I'm I'm not a big fan of
at the beginning when you're starting on
your journey but this is the top-down
approach right it's like our our 10
minute plus videos we're going long form
and this may be all you need to create
Terrell says just landed a partnership
doing this yeah it's honestly a great
challenge for you guys
for this month is think about three
people that if they knew who you were
three companies or people that they knew
who you were and they were talking about
you would make a meaningful difference
to Growing your business
and then reach out to them and invite
them to be a guest on your new show even
if it's a brand new show
reach out to them and be a guest on your
show so you build a relationship from
there we we take the best moments and
turn into micro content so most of what
we do on all these platforms me
personally is we're taking YouTube
content so we're making the long form
videos and then we cut it up
you take the best moments and you turn
them into all of these different
platforms
you can do it yourself through editing
or you can you can hire somebody whether
it's somebody who's local whether it's
somebody on Fiverr whether it's somebody
who's in your community who you're doing
an exchange of services you're coaching
them and they're helping you with
content
this is not doesn't have to be heavily
edited it doesn't have to be highly
skilled again like focus on the quality
of thought more than the production
quality Wendy says sending out invites
today let's go Wendy that's what I'm
talking about
uh and then and then again like let's
make it lead to business so that leads
to a lead magnet it's not just creating
content into a void we want to lead them
to a lead magnet so we had
um Erica who was on with me yesterday on
Instagram
uh her Instagram bio link wasn't working
right it's like okay well that's the
first thing we need to pick so when I
click on your link it actually goes to
your website but ideally it leads to a
lead magnet so we can capture their
email addresses and then that's where
the selling is done so we're not making
sales videos that go up on YouTube
Instagram Etc
if you make a video it's it's not the
end of the world like I might make a
post on when momentum comes out my book
right I might make a post to say hey
momentum came out go check it out but it
won't get nearly as much reach because
it's it's a sales pitch
so if all your videos are just sales
pitches it's Dead on Arrival nobody's
going to watch it whether it's YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock it doesn't matter
so we want people to get to know us love
us want to connect with us to get their
email address and then we're giving them
value emails and then we're selling them
right and selling them it
I guess it has a negative connotation
it's like we're giving them value we're
providing our service we're helping them
and then whatever you're trying to sell
right these are some examples
so this is still the model that I use
this is still the mod I recommend using
you could have strategies for each of
these individual platforms
uh uh it can just become overwhelming
but I don't want you to get overwhelmed
and feel like it's impossible and then
nothing happens and we don't stay
consistent Brian is saying I should
probably stick with the past faster
freedom for now right so the three
models and build the serve fast passive
Freedom which is the direct messaging
Outreach Partnerships and then content
those are the three models
it all depends on on how quickly you
need to bring in business like if you
need to bring in business right away
then it's sales it's Outreach it's
direct messaging people it's it's
one-on-one connections and you're
sending 1500 messages a day connecting
with people and some people will pick
that up if I if I really want it I need
to sell movement makers or need to sell
momentum like the easiest thing to me to
do when we have the easiest the most
effective short-term thing today would
be start messaging everybody
like anybody who follows me anybody
who's got a an issue with momentum
anybody posting around how they're stuck
or they're they're not in momentum mode
they're procrastinating they're
overthinking direct messaging and some
people will pick it up
it's a lot of grunt work but it's the
fastest way to bring in deals the
partnership is really slow and then it
goes really fast so if one is going to
do the Outreach and send three three
messages today there's that's slow
you're building a relationship but once
you get the right relationship they say
yes then it can go really fast because
that one person can can send you ten a
hundred a thousand client sales Etc and
then the content is the slowest but it's
the most effective long term
so that the videos that you make now
they may not get a result right now but
in a month and in two months and six
months and 12 months and 24 months the
videos are still there still driving
leads attention interest awareness for
what you're doing so it just depends on
how quickly you need to make things
happen
I want to talk about storytelling public
speaking and I want to I want to go
deeper with you guys today when I was
thinking about what to talk about for
today I thought you know what we should
go deep with the questions that you guys
have so think about the question you've
got what's the most important thing
you're struggling with right now with
storytelling and public speaking and
whether we'll do it in the text chat or
we bring people up on stage and talk
about it I really want to go deep to
make sure that you're getting value out
of this like how do we take this
speaking career of yours to The Next
Step storytelling and public speaking
where are you struggling right now
and your question will probably be
really valuable to everybody else
watching as well all right we got a
couple hands coming up so doctor uh
let's bring Dr o up
good morning I'm a Storyteller but I
haven't
honed it down so
my question is
how do I say one story stick with it to
have the call to action what I want
people to gain from it because I can
tell stories but I haven't quite
figured out how to make it work for the
other person so the best stories that
you say from stage are the ones where
you are helping people first right like
the best stories that I've told are
because I help people one-on-one first
because when you're speaking live on
stage to a group of people you don't get
a lot of fantastic feedback like you can
kind of look at their faces and see
what's going on but they have a lot of
thoughts and and and yeah buts and
what-ifs in their head but they're not
expressing them but when you sit down
with somebody one-on-one
you get the feedback
you get to see you get to see what
they're thinking you get to hear the
real thoughts going on in their head
and so my best stories have come the
stories that I tell on stage the stories
I just told in Vegas I've told countless
times to people one-on-one and I know
how to tell the story so that it moves
them to a result
you can have a million different stories
and it's awesome that you're a
Storyteller Stories the the point is to
get people to move towards some kind of
action so the key is figuring out which
story to tell in which context so if I'm
If You're Gonna Go on stage and speak
what's the end goal that you want to
have happen
and then what's the right Story to Tell
in this situation
does that make sense
I'm figuring it out
I would practice telling more stories to
more individual people
and ask them what they thought
gotcha and especially the resistance
like where does it not make sense
okay I'll tell you a quick story
okay
I had eye surgery
um
the end of last month
and when I went to my doctor's office he
said I could go back to work I work in
the ER and I decided I need a doctor's
note
not to work till July so that I can sit
with what I really want to do which is
in this space
and so
the story for me is I have no income
so I have to figure
if I really want to be in this space or
not because just the way to help people
is to be able to be consistent and to
have a way to pay my bills otherwise I'm
not going to be in this space I'll go
back because every time I'm in the year
I can't I can't fit into this space it's
a different Zone
so the story for me is to tell people
that are 60 years old in healthcare that
they need to live their best life
even though they've lived a best a
better life in something they know it's
okay to Pivot
because if you don't
what are you going to do at the end of
life
and so I mean that that's I mean that's
why I did it that's the story I told
myself
and so I'm just trying to figure
how to take life situations and make it
stories to help people
make decisions and I made that decision
to say I burned that bridge is it a
permanent bridge I think it is
but I have to make it work
that's why I came on the call
no I love it and
your your journey
becomes the story
so a couple things in there right like
you haven't done the thing yet right you
haven't built the successful career
outside of healthcare yet no so we can't
say here's what I've done you know look
at what I've done
but
the story is that you have the courage
to try
and the willingness to try
and you're going to make mistakes and
you're going to have self-doubt and
you're going to not be sure if it's
working out or not
and the willingness to try is the
inspiration
so
if if we're telling a story
if my main call Action was I want people
to be willing to try like if that's the
message be willing to try we will need
to try right you can have tons of
stories but my takeaway from this one is
hey be willing to try
so when our people are around you or
they hear your speech or they watch your
video I need to feel like I I should go
off I've got an idea I need to be
willing to try if Dr O's going to go off
and do it and and I need to be willing
to try as well
so the message is be willing to try then
you can tell a story around it
gotcha let me tell you guys I I'm I'm
here trying to I'm trying to do it too
like I haven't started living my life
yet I'm trying I don't know all the
steps I'm trying to figure it out I know
that I don't want to see any ER anymore
because it makes me feel X like whatever
it actually makes you feel
and I know I want to be in a different
spot and I'm tired of of people telling
me that I'm too old
and I'm tired of telling myself that I'm
told and that I can't change
and then whatever whatever like the
actual thoughts are in your head that
when you wake up because you don't wake
up every day and like I'm gonna go crush
this goal so like what what are the
actual thoughts in your head because
that's what brings us in and makes it
personal okay
and then you share and I'm I still get
up every day because I'm willing to try
and I want to make this happen
so that when I walk away I've been
inspired by the story
but my takeaway is be willing to try
gotcha thank you very much now when
you're talking to somebody one-on-one
then you can ask for feedbacks okay so
what are you gonna do now
and you see where this are they actually
off ready to try something or are they
still dealing with their own doubts and
insecurities
because when you're speaking on stage
again you're speaking to a a group of
people you don't get that feedback
but if you can if you can structure you
have so many stories to tell cool those
they don't all have to fit into one
video or one speech
one main message per video per speech
that when I walk away with if you think
like the event I just came back from in
Vegas
it's like it was three days four days I
don't remember so many speakers
everybody gets up there's another speech
another speech that's like it's speech
overload like you guys have all been to
events and it's just crazy speech
overload so to to
hope that somebody remembers everything
that you're gonna say is impossible
so it's like what's the one thing that
I'm going to get from your message
that I can take away that you are you
are the most valuable person for me from
that event
and it's such that you having that
intention as opposed to just standing up
saying I got a bunch of stories to tell
gotcha good luck all right Milko in the
house I saw him bouncing what do we got
Milko my question it's not very well
formed uh but
for me because from what I know a good
storytelling you need to show emotion
and it's kind of like last time we kind
of covered this and you showed us how
you actually took your 700 videos or
what was them or something like that to
find your uh self and be yourself on
camera so for me because I usually I'm
not used to sharing my emotions in any
way so I usually uh I'm usually quite
intense when I coach people but I don't
share my emotions and I know that for
example for storytelling when you show
your emotions when you share them uh
it's much better and people can relate
to you more so I'm trying to
find this voice but I can't really make
the difference because sometimes I I
feel like I'm really putting it there
and I'm kind of showing my emotions and
stuff like that and then it turns out
the video that it's not uh or someone
else is telling me that it's not really
it sounds a bit a bit uh not genuine and
so on so so kind of I'm not sure where
I'm going with this but you know
so listen I mean if you if you go back
and watch our session from a couple
weeks ago is you know like I
self-criticized my videos or critique
them going back and and uh when I got
the feedback to have more motion you see
my very my very beginning videos that
the content was still almost still what
I talked about now
the delivery was way off it's like okay
guys so I got a question from my reader
and you know it's like it's just super
boring watching it back and then when I
got the feedback to try to do more
motion I felt forced right like as I was
critiquing my videos like look at that
video like I'm trying there is more
energy but it's not real Evan energy
it's a forced energy but it's it's
better than what it was but it's not
where it needs to be and it's still
pushing through that discomfort to uh
practice and work on it because it was
80 there some of the things are right
but I had to keep
I had to keep trying it on to like make
make it fit for me one of the best
things that helped me and this advice I
told Alex too who's in the house so we
could talk about him
um when Alex first started doing stories
at TDS uh China van salsa he was he was
doing stories at the front of the class
I was doing stories on videos it all
sucked I mean like what we all suck at
the beginning right and Alex and Alex
can add to the chat if he wants kind of
sharing stuff but
um it was really bad and and the points
were still good but the delivery was
just really really bad
um and so the exercise I gave him was
whenever you feel the emotion film
so whenever you feel like that
Breakthrough video for me I figured what
number was like 670 something
um
was because I came back from that event
I was trying to help entrepreneur I was
so frustrated and so I I just filmed I
had no idea what I was gonna say and I
just filmed and the energy was on point
the content wasn't as good but the
energy was so much better
and it's the energy that's actually
going to carry the day and so whenever
you feel the emotion if if you just come
out of movement makers and you feel
grateful or you just come out of a
coaching call and you feel frustrated or
whatever has happened like you feel
emotions throughout your day
they just may not be there when you're
about to press record on the camera
so the trick is have your phone with you
which we probably all do and and when
you feel that emotion you film
and it does two things
one it it gets you
the practice of speaking from your heart
because we're speaking from our head
with most of our videos so it gets you
the practice of speaking with your heart
and letting that Express because you
feel what it feels like but you you
haven't practiced vocalizing what it
feels like and so it gets you that
practice the second thing is when you go
to try to tell that story again if
you're gonna then tell that story on
stage you can tell that story in a
future video you can go back and watch
how you delivered it when you were
actually in that state and then you can
think back to yeah that's how I felt
because it's hard to manufacture that
sometimes when you're just sitting at
home on your ball kind of Bounce Around
figuring out you know talking about food
choices right
um so that's the best activity that I
would recommend it's like try to catch
it during the week and then film even if
you don't post it just try to catch an
emotion any uh a positive or negative
emotion
and film it and don't stress if it sucks
and don't stress if it's not well
thought out or
um you don't really know what you're
saying as you go but just practice that
because the more you practice that the
better you'll get at it and again you
can go watch it back and say yeah that's
what it feels like to to have that that
thought again so you could get out of
your head and into your heart
thank you so very helpful yeah I
remember one time where like when I was
really grinding on Alex to do this we're
at a uh we're at a dance event so we we
hosted these dance parties once a week
or so and um he was uh
uh he I forget he had some kind of
emotion right he was upset or he was
happy I don't remember what it was like
dude go film like now yeah go go film
now and and then he he filmed yeah it's
like that's what you need to train
yourself to do you're feeling emotional
film film even if it's just for yourself
to get the repetition down
we got an important topic to talk about
today how to accelerate the growth of
your movement I'm excited let's dive
into it so the fast passive Freedom this
is again inbuilt to serve
you want to think about the social media
accounts where you're going to live on
and so you think about Instagram you
think about LinkedIn think about Twitter
YouTube uh Facebook right you think
about your main social media accounts
you start by having just the account you
create a professional picture bio and
content right in all of any social media
Network you're going to have the option
to add a picture bio and content and now
gear your picture and your bio towards
your ideal customer what I want you
thinking of if my ideal customer landed
on my page if you're looking at
Instagram right if your ideal client
landed on your Instagram page what they
want to call you what they want to work
with you what they want to potentially
hire you is there enough on there that
makes you think this person knows what
they're talking about they are the
expert they can help me I need to reach
out right so this is what we want to be
doing across all of our social accounts
what's the picture you're going to use
what's your bio that you're going to add
and what content you're going to put up
a lot of times there's inconsistencies
across different platforms there's no
real thought or care consideration to it
make a picture that's a headshot I want
you zoomed in not a full body shot
unless you're in Fitness
maybe there's a case right to see the
whole body but even then people resonate
with the face I want people to recognize
you instantly and so have the same
picture across all your social media
accounts
uh and then again a buyer that speaks to
to your ideal client my my idea is I
want people to come look at your account
and then say I want to work with this
person next we're going to create 10
pieces of content and that's it so what
do you actually make the 10 pieces of
I laid out in in the book we'll go over
super quickly here it starts with number
one your who right so what's your most
important core value why tell me where
it comes from tell me why it's so
important to you show me why you care
like this is this is how you stand out
versus most people most people's
accounts are boring most companies
accounts are super boring most people
are saying the exact same thing and so
don't make it look like a resume you're
who it's your most important core value
if I'm making a a post about believe it
should it should ooze
confidence and and energy and
awesomeness right and from the heart so
what is your most important core value
and then make an emotional piece of
content that could be a video or could
be written form just something that if I
read it I'm gonna feel that same thing
I'm gonna feel Believe by reading your
belief post two is explain your why so
tell me why you're doing what you're
doing tell me your pain that you went
through and tell me how it led to your
purpose right all the stuff that we're
talking about in the book
talk to me about your darkest moment and
how you came out of it
people don't want to learn from the
perfect person people don't want to
learn from the person who looks like
they have it all figured out because it
makes people feel like well they're
perfect I can't be like that I need to
know that you went through the same
thing I went through
that is the thing that will make people
connect to you and so I need to see a
post talking about your why right and
this this format
can be it could be nine YouTube or ten
YouTube videos it could be 10 Instagram
posts 10 LinkedIn posts 10 tweets right
I just need to have content there so
it's not a debt account with just a face
and a bio
and then three is give me your how give
me an overview of your recipe for
success we talk about in the book where
basically how did you get out of the
problem that you were in and how can you
then use that as a tool to teach other
people how they can get out of it as
well well that should be one post one of
the things that a lot of people struggle
with when they're creating content is
they're all over the map you wanna you
have so much in your head and you want
to say so many things but then when you
look at a post it's it's a mix of 18
different messages tighten it down Focus
one key thought per post make me feel
one thing if you make me feel ten things
I don't know what to do next right one
key thing per post so you're who your
why your how are three are the ten
toasts I want to see in your Mason 10
pack of content treat it like you're
brochure this is your brochure this is
your flyer this is you talking about
what you're doing and showcasing that
you are an expert because if I'm coming
to your page your profile with a problem
one that you know that you can solve I
need to feel like you are the person to
help me four to six is your recipe
breakdown so how you got out of it teach
me
so the first three posts are more
inspiring more motivational more you
understand me you know what I'm going
through because you've been through it
as well right it connects with me on a
human level your next three are now
going to be you teaching me something
so specifically what did you do or what
can I do to help me get out of the
problem that you know how to solve
and that's three different posts if you
can mix it up between if I'm taking
Instagram if you make it up between
pictures videos fire captions awesome
same thing for LinkedIn
pictures videos fire caption if you're
doing Pinterest you have an amazing
picture but write some awesome caption
step seven is results I want to see your
results I want to see uh your client
results of people who you've helped show
me their results so now if you think
about this Arc of a story we're telling
our first three are these emotional
pieces that makes me connect to you as a
human our next three is telling me
exactly what I need to do to get out of
the hole that I'm in right step by step
and don't worry like nobody's gonna take
that thing and just run with it and
crush it people are afraid to give up
their secrets you need to Showcase that
you are an expert and you know what
you're talking about so don't be afraid
about giving them a high level step one
do this and then results so you're
showing me
uh what happened tell me again your
story somebody else's story we're taking
people on a journey on an arc so that
we're likely way more likely to convert
people to want to hire us want to work
with us eight nine now show me more
examples so showing me again more
specifics take me on a journey of of you
or people you've helped dive deeper if
you haven't helped anybody yet give me a
hypothetical example right show me who
you would be helping uh hypothetical of
a mom who has you know these scenarios
or a dad like this or an entrepreneur
just starting off right
um I could if it were me and I was just
getting started it'd be a story about
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
their first business off the off the
ground if you look at books like the go
Giver
um Bob berg a friend of the channel it's
it's a parable right they're teaching
through
uh a narrative that doesn't actually
exist it's not a real character but
you're learning through those stories so
what is a story if you don't have any
actual examples or clients you can share
and then your last point is is Hope
give me hope make me feel hope uh make
me feel like it's possible make me feel
like I'm not alone make me feel like
where I'm at right now doesn't have to
be where I'm going to finish uh it makes
a huge huge difference because if you've
now taken me on this journey of you've
connected with me emotionally you've
you've shown me that you know what
you're talking about and that I can get
through it you've shown me examples and
results of other people who've done it
and you've done it as well and then you
leave with an inspirational message of
hope that that it's possible for me as
well you're giving people an arc that
it's people are going through these 10
posts they're way more likely to want to
work with you and so this can help as a
structure give you Clarity over the
content to create for your accounts and
I would apply this for all of my
accounts I would apply this for every
single platform that you create an
account on and then stop the goal here
is not to be the thought leader content
producer making making pieces of content
every single day getting out there this
is the fast pass to Freedom this this is
now we're going to start doing Outreach
the goal here is I want if people come
to your account to see you as the expert
next step is how do I get people to come
to my account but you got to give them
something on your account that makes you
seem credible and I want to work with
you hire you contact you take the next
step with you right it's worth spending
time on all of these uh normally when
I'm when I'm talking about making
content on the thought leadership side I
say don't worry so much about production
quality don't worry about having the
perfect words each time just get it out
there these ones it's worth treated like
a marketing brochure it's worth spend a
little bit more time on not necessarily
from having a camera crew come in and
film you and making it perfect but even
from the angle of just you being
prepared you not just throwing up your
first take you really spending time on
each to go over it because this is now
going to do all the heavy lifting for us
once we get people coming to our page so
how do we actually get people to see our
account
you reach out and there's two key ways
search and hashtags and depending on the
platform you're looking at uh some you
can search just for keywords if you go
to YouTube you can Search keywords you
can see what people are going through uh
hashtags are almost on every platform
Instagram you can't search you can only
go through hashtags or your searching is
through hashtags and you're looking for
people who are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with right your
purpose comes to your pain the people
who are going to help are the people who
currently are who you used to be the
great thing about social media is that
people are sharing all the time people
are sharing what they're going through
they're sharing what they're struggling
with they're sharing what they what
their inner demons are they're sharing
they're sharing it so you're looking for
the people who are talking about the
thing that you can help with for example
in in the book I talk about uh a guy
named Michael who helped me overcome my
concussion and we created a a template
for him to say hey look for people who
are talking about concussions on
Instagram look at people who are posting
because when you get a concussion a lot
of people with images are going to post
Instagram
and most of the time people are just
posting to to get support from their
friends uh and sometimes to complain
right
but if you're there reaching out for
help
you're saying hey I know what you're
going through I've been through that
myself I want to help I've got ideas for
you that might be able to help you what
are they going to do next
so that's interesting this is the only
person reaching out to me uh they're
gonna go check out your account
what are they going to say in your
account they're going to see an amazing
picture an amazing bio and 10 pieces of
amazing content that we just spent all
this time working on right so the idea
is every day we're going to reach out to
people every day we're going to reach
out to people we're going to send DMS
we're gonna we're gonna text them we're
gonna send them messages
offering hope
offering guidance offering uh what I
like to do is offer a call so what I
recommend is offering a free call with
people
and guide them through how you can help
and give them value on the call like
your point of a free call is they want
to come back and work with you again
they want to they should be asking how
much does it cost to hire you okay can I
can I bring you on as my coach can I
continue working with you somehow if
you're not getting that after a free
call then you didn't do a good enough
job on the call yet in terms of
providing value and so you you keep
practicing right you keep practicing
doing more and more free calls we have
our picture we have our link we have our
bio we have our 10 pieces of content and
we stop posting content and just start
outreaching
this is the fastest way to start getting
clients to start building your business
today guys we have a super super
important topic when to push
versus when to break and this is a
really important one because
I think uh
we have moments where we are our best we
have moments where we are showing up
where we are motivated we're inspired
where we're doing our thing where we
know that what we're doing is important
where we feel the impact maybe you join
movement makers and you've got a lot of
inspiration from the session maybe
somebody left you a great comment but
then there's going to be days when you
wake up and you don't feel like it and
you don't have the energy and it's not
as high and you you have that voice
inside your head that says
tomorrow do it do it tomorrow right it's
okay you deserve a break you've been
working too hard
what do you do when that voice comes in
when all your friends tell you to take
it easy to relax and take a break I have
a rule
where I want to spend 95 of my time
pushing harder and five percent of my
time giving myself a break because there
are definitely some times we actually
really do need a break we need to take
care of yourself where you need to relax
we've actually pushed too hard and
that's okay but most of the time I think
you need to push harder I think that's
the mindset of high Achievers and I'm
going to break down today some of the
stories just my own experience you can
learn from as well as some strategies
you can use to help you identify when to
push harder and when to break so first
thing I'm going to talk about here how
did the side between pushing versus
breaking
pass the pillow test
so let's dive in so again 95 push five
percent break this is my own internal
metric this is what I tell myself
95 of the time when I'm feeling low
energy tired don't feel like doing it
have have every excuse in the world not
to do it every reason everybody else
left me off the hook 95 of the time me
Evan Carl Michael emotionally the voice
in my head is
go do it
you have to go do it this becomes an
identity thing
this is who I want to be Evan Carmichael
at his best self is the guy who's off
pushing for one more
say no that little voice in my head and
then five percent is to take a break
take it easy it's okay to rest right uh
you can figure out what the numbers are
for you but for achievers
you guys got big movements ahead of you
it should lean more towards the push
than the break
so let me talk to you about Tuesday
we've been going through some crazy
times here at the Carmichael household
uh we just came back from a trip we went
out to uh to Kelowna our first family
trip in the past two years which is
which is amazing uh there's no Corona
out there at all so everybody's around
no masks in uh indoor dining all of it
we're here in Toronto's a lot of still
issues you can't do in your dining and
wearing masterfield we're going out
there but we come back here
I decided I want to redo my office and
redo my bedroom uh and do floors I want
new floors so you probably can't see
them from this angle because I moved my
desk and it's a little chaotic but we
got brand new floors in the office it
wasn't ready it was supposed to be ready
on Monday
we got the wrong floors it didn't work
so Tuesday was a disaster
Tuesday is normally my YouTube filming
day okay
we can't sleep on our bedroom on Monday
night because they put half the floors
in they got to take them out I I can't
do anything in our second bedroom
because it's full of all the junk from
the first bedroom
take our bed and put it down in the
kitchen the only spot and so we slept in
the kitchen
Monday night okay Tuesday Morning Comes
Around I had a terrible sleep I'm still
jet lag Nina's got an early morning
acupuncture apartment and Tuesday is my
espresso video days I gotta go film
espresso I usually Drive Nina to
wherever she needs to go she goes and
does her stuff and I film videos in the
car it's been our tradition
she wakes up I am dead tired
and she said I'm gonna I'm gonna go you
sleep in a little bit I'll come back and
get you in a couple hours
this is the point when that little voice
really matters
because in my head I'm thinking I'm
tired I'm jet lagged
she's gonna come back in two hours and
I'll be able to film then anyway I can
still get it done right we we create a
logical reason how we can still follow
through I can still get it done
I'm sleeping in the kitchen
I deserve this I just came back it's
crazy but then literally 10 seconds
later it's like no I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming I get up we rush
out and then I go and film videos and
instead of just making usual uh espresso
day I'll make seven videos I made 15.
just because just because that's what
Evan Carmichael does right and not that
I'm some superhero like it's something
that's been built
every time you have that little voice
inside your head that says Nah you know
you shouldn't do it like no
there's no reason why I can't
and then go a little bit harder push a
little bit more now I went a little
crazy because I was really in the zone
and I love when I'm in the zone I love
staying in the zone as much as possible
so instead of doing seven I finished off
the ten that were on my list and then I
asked for five more and then finished
those five as well
come on Evan Carmichael let's go right
and this is for for all of you the same
thing you have that little voice that
tells you you can't do it gives you all
the reasons why you can't
and then you show yourself that you can
and not just that you can do that thing
but you can do more
and what it does is start to shift the
identity
it starts to take away that little voice
in your head so that it doesn't have to
take you I used to lose an entire day I
never lost weeks or months right but I
would lose an entire day some one little
thing happened that that derailed me the
whole day would be gone like okay I'll
figure it out tomorrow
the goal is to try to get that to a
shorter window as possible
so instead of I take an entire day for
you to bounce back it's you know a
couple hours within an hour to then half
an hour to then five minutes to then you
know 15 seconds you know stuff is going
to happen
the the answer is not to avoid all of
the pains in life stuff is going to
happen to you it's how do you react to
them and then get back on track
showing yourself that you're the person
who does it
so I want to share a recent example
because that just happened Tuesday the
the most painful examples back in 2019
when I broke my neck and I had a goal of
going live every day on Instagram I said
on my tour I'm gonna go live every
single day on Instagram every day 90
days every day I'm going live on
Instagram no matter what little did I
know I was going to be in a hospital
with a concussion and break my neck in
two spots but that no matter what
made me want to do it
and this was me I broke my neck on
Nina's birthday March 15th is Nina's
birthday and we broke my neck and was in
the hospital and I said I need to go
live and the doctor was like you can't
go live and Nina's like you're crazy
what are you doing like no no I said I
was gonna go live every day I can't even
see the phone at this point right I've
got a concussion I don't know what's
happening on the screen but even if it's
for 60 seconds
I'm gonna go live and most of my live
streams were an hour long right
I don't know how long this one ended up
being it was probably a couple minutes I
just gave people a quick update it looks
like I'm dying
so Doug watler who's who's a movement
maker and long time you know friend uh
took this screenshot and posted his
Instagram he's like Doug I look like I'm
dead I mean he took it in black and
white for whatever reason I wasn't
filming in black and white and posted it
but what I'm I'm I'm happy and I see you
know Adam Duran who gave a thumbs up in
the chat here on this picture uh who's
also now Muka makers welcome board Adam
this might have been might have been
crazy uh might have been too stupid
but I'm proud of it it was probably the
worst live stream I've ever done I don't
know what I said it was probably very
incoherent just telling people what
happened
and then I'm gonna be okay
but it was likely my worst livestream of
all time but one of the ones that I'm
most proud of because there was every
reason why I couldn't do it and then I
still went and did it right
so fast forward March 29th so two weeks
later I'm back to filming videos
now they're not the most coherent videos
I'm not the best on camera I'm wearing
this neck brace I've got this giant scab
on my forehead right I look at myself
how many times have you looked at
yourself and like I can't make videos
today because what because my hair is a
little bit out of place
looking at you Alex
because because I gained a little bit of
weight because whatever right we've all
I'm sitting here with a neck brace on
there's Alex taking his hat out there we
go you know with this giant scab on my
forehead like let's go right and I had
that guys I had that voice too it's like
I can't make a video with this crazy
thing on my forehead with this neck
brace on I can't even fit into my
clothes I'm wearing I might be naked
under this I'm not sure but I may I
might have a t-shirt on I couldn't lift
my arms to get anything on I couldn't
put my my usual believe hoodie on so I
put on a jacket
this is an Arizona or something this is
like super warm
but I'm wearing a jacket
start making videos because I had that
voice in my head again telling me you
can't do this look at you you're a mess
everybody would every who would not
understand right like everybody would
understand if they didn't make content
given what happened but I don't want
that like that's the standard I was on a
walk with with Nina this morning taking
the dogs out before coming here and
she's like your standards are just way
up here this is a normal person and your
standards are in the sky it's like yes
exactly that's what we want and by you
raising your standards you lift
everybody else up around you as well so
it's not that I don't have these voices
I still have those voices telling me I
can't do it and and all the reasons why
I can't it's fighting that voice every
single day
by April uh the scab was gone uh I still
can't fit into my hoodie so I I went to
the store I was tired of filming in just
my one jacket so we went to a store and
we bought this giant like double XL Nike
sweater
that was the only thing I could fit into
on a day-to-day basis so you can see it
there I've gained some weight like look
at me I'm barely moving guys my my
pillow's behind me I'm in so much pain
every day we're continuing the tour look
at how much look at my face look at how
much weight I've gained so now I'm
self-conscious about my weight I've just
gained 15 pounds because I'm lying on on
a couch all day because I can't move I
can't film now I can't film being this
fat Evan
again Voice to my head no I have to do
it now because that was in my head now I
have to do it because that was the
reason
I refuse to not make content because of
that voice I refuse to play small
because of that voice right could I take
a break yes is this where I'm proud of
myself for taking a break no so I'm
gonna make videos
and then fast forward to may now I'm I'm
healing a little bit more you can see I
lost some weight on my face if you go
back uh I'm at home now I can fit into
my shirts again I'm still wearing the
neck brace still healing but still
making content
still making content my health card we
have a photo health card here in Ontario
and when we got back I had to renew my
health card because my wallet was stolen
in LA on our trip and we'd get to the
place to take the picture and I'm
wearing my neck brace and he's like
don't you want to take your neck brace
off for for the camera because this is
going to be on your health card for the
next five years if you like scrunched up
here with this neck brace on like
that on my health card for the next five
years like I showed up
take my picture that we all get
self-conscious of in my neck brace when
I could have taken it off just because
right like it's that daily constant
attacking of that little voice inside
your head telling you all the reasons
why that you can't win
okay so I filmed throughout the whole
thing there wasn't a time that I that I
took a day off on filming now in 2019
October
my family my family dog died Toby and uh
he he passed away we put him down he had
really bad cancer he was struggling for
a long time and
um they passed away on on a Tuesday
which was our my filming day
and it was the morning and it was my
family all there and my dad and I stayed
in the room with with him while you know
they gave him the final injection and
everybody else left and it was super
emotional and I just
I couldn't imagine going home and
filming
you know and so I uh I told
Christina my editor let's do some
mashups we still have to get videos up
but let's do some content and let's just
explain it at the beginning that
I I skipped the filming day you know so
we wrote this Toby my family dog my
family's dog passed away from cancer
this week I didn't do my regular
espresso filming I hope you understand
I Love You Toby still can't believe
you're gone thank you for an amazing 11
years and I'm still kind of getting a
little
choked up just looking at it
but I was okay with um with not filming
on that day
you know I was okay with it
like this is where I would film through
a broken neck I would film through
everything else but but um
you know for me this was the moment
where like okay in the past however many
years this is the time that I'm not I'm
not filming and I'm okay with that
now for those of you who have dogs maybe
you get what I'm saying for those of you
you might think I'm crazy
um
that's okay too
it's not judging somebody else's reasons
it's are you proud of yourself
for why you didn't do it I'm okay that I
didn't film that week we still got
videos up I'm okay with it
that was a five percent
right 95 push five percent break I'm
okay with that five percent being a
break
if you want to watch the full version of
this video as well as train live with me
twice a month to help you build your
movement and be around some other
amazing people just like you check out
my movement makers program the link to
join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join